ein bild spezial herzlich willkommen
denn der generalsekretär der nato ist
bei uns zu gast exklusiv bei bild jens
stoltenberg chef des größten
militärbündnisses der welt hier sieht
man wie er gerade an kommt es geht um
nicht weniger als um krieg und frieden
in europa wird putin in die ukraine
einen marschieren die gefahr wird immer
größer wie wird der westen wie wird die
nato reagieren und welche folgen hat das
auch für uns in deutschland vor wenigen
minuten ist jens stoltenberg im axel
springer hochhaus in berlin angekommen
und wird gleich von meinem kollegen
teilweise die richtigen fragen gestellt
bekommen was kommt auf uns zu über 100
tausend russische soldaten sind an der
grenze zur ukraine aufmarschiert kiew
die hauptstadt ist nur 1200 kilometer
luftlinie von berlin entfernt wird putin
es wagen in die ukraine einzumarschieren
und damit womöglich einen flächenbrand
in europa auslösen können wir uns
wirklich aus einem militärischen
konflikt heraushalten so wie es die
linie der bundesregierung derzeit ist
wie sehr würden massive
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen russland
auch unsere eigene wirtschaft treffen
und was bedeutet das für unsere
energieversorgung die in großem maße von
russland abhängig ist dies sei ein
konflikt der uns direkt betrifft heute
morgen war die neue deutsche
außenministerin annalena baerbock beim
russischen außenminister lawrow in
moskau nachdem sie gestern bereits in
kiew war gerade erst im amt und schon
mitten in einer möglichen weltkrise
konfrontiert mit einem russischen
aussenminister der mit allen wassern
gewaschen ist eigentlich sollte es nach
einer stunde ein presse statement geben
dort das gespräch dauerte weit über zwei
stunden bevor die beiden ihre statements
abgaben annalena baerbock sagte mir war
wichtig schnell nach antritt der neuen
bundesregierung hierher zu kommen ich
bin mit einer dicken gesprächs mappe
gekommen sie ist dick weil es eine ganze
reihe von themen zu besprechen gibt in
denen wir große teils fundamentale
meinungsverschiedenheiten
haben die schuld für diese
meinungsverschiedenheiten sid der
russische außenminister lawrow
allerdings nicht bei russland wir haben
auch so internationale foren gewusst wir
haben als große aufmerksamkeit der
beziehungen der russischen revolution
und der europäischen union gewesen ist
da gibt es viele probleme und leider
sind eine antirussische linie russe ist
festgestellt worden und auch manche anti
russisch eingestellt der länder nicht
liefern
es wurde auch besorgnis erklärte
unsererseits für die konzentrierung von
nato kräften an der russischen grenze
und wir haben auch über initiativen
gesprochen die russland die russische
seite
hervor gebracht hat um damit
zuverlässige juristische und politische
garantien der sicherheit zu
gewährleisten die russische föderation
soll darf nicht als eine seite des
konflikts hervorgehoben werden solche
versuche haben wir beobachtet und es
wurde versucht auf russland die
verantwortung für den mangel an
fortschritten zu übertragen wir
verlassen sich darauf dass unsere
deutschen kollegen
einfluss nehmen auf ihre
partner in kiew und damit diese endlich
die verpflichtungen die sie übernommen
haben auch verwirklichen was nun das
erfahren wir jetzt gleich im bild
explosiv gesprächen mit nato-chef
stoltenberg ist direkt aus dem
bundeskanzleramt zu uns gekommen wo er
zuvor mit bundeskanzler olaf scholz
gesprochen hatte das ist das statement
danach
die nato
und das transatlantische bündnis sind
ein garant für die deutsche sicherheit
und auch für die europäische sicherheit
das war so das ist so und das wird auch
in der zukunft so sein
wir erleben in diesen tagen wieder wie
wichtig das ist dass wir gemeinsam
unseren beitrag dazu leisten stabilität
frieden und sicherheit in europa zu
gewährleisten
es ist keine selbstverständlichkeit dass
das immer der fall ist und gerade die
lage in und um die ukraine macht uns
deutlich wie sehr diese sicherheit
gefährdet ist wir sind sehr besorgt dann
schauen wir auf diese lage in der
ukraine bereitet man sich bereits auf
den schlimmsten fall vor bild reporter
paul ronzheimer ist vor ort und hat uns
diese bilder geschickt
sie robben durch den sand schmeißen sich
in die büsche hören auf kommandos
ein russischer angriff auf die ukraine
wird immer wahrscheinlicher
das säbelrasseln ist inzwischen so laut
dass sich sogar zivilisten auf putins
mögliche invasionen vorbereiten wie
ernst die lage ist zeigt diese
militärübung das sind keine soldaten
sondern zivilisten die hier trainieren
aus großer angst und sorge dass putins
truppen auch in kiew einfallen könnten
und hier ihre familien bedrohen deswegen
trainieren sie den ernstfall deswegen
trainieren sie hier jedes wochenende wie
sie sich dann gegen russische truppen
verteidigen können makler jussif ist
eine solche zivilisten im normalen leben
ist die 45-jährige angestellte bei einem
großkonzern forscht in klinischen
studien seit mehreren monaten kommt sie
samstags hierher
es war eine weitere eskalation an der
grenze also bringt putin die truppen an
die ukrainische grenze und ich habe
einen artikel über
territorialverteidigung gesehen ich habe
vorher nichts davon gewusst aber als ich
den artikel sah entschied ich mich dafür
sie alle haben angst dass russlands
präsident wladimir putin ernst machen
könnte und auch die ukrainische
hauptstadt kiew angreift
wir haben alle etwas was uns wertvoll
ist es ist unser land es sind unsere
gräber sind die familien unserer
familien wir wissen ja auch dass die
kommunikation zwischen putin und beiden
nicht sehr erfolgreich war und putin das
risiko einer eskalation immer hoch hält
mehr als 100 tausend russische soldaten
stehen an der grenze bereit für den
einmarsch in die ukraine kampflos wollen
sich die bürger dort nicht ergeben
dass also die lage auf der ukrainischen
seite bevor wir mit jens stoltenberg
sprechen dem nato-chef schauen wir kurz
auf die andere seite auf die russische
seite um den gesamteindruck zu haben
unser chefreporter peter tiede war
vergangene woche noch dort ist jetzt
hier bei mir im studio peter was war
dein eindruck von dem truppenaufmarsch
dort wirklich massiv sind massiv truppen
verlegt worden an die an die ukrainische
grenze das ist ohnehin ein militär bild
wenn man von rostov am don ganz im süden
schwarzes mehr hochfährt bis nach wunsch
das ist seitdem ukraine krieg
hochgerüstet und jetzt ist es noch
einmal hoch gerüstete es sind wirklich
massive truppenverlegungen teilweise
sind über wochen nachts die an den
großen eisenbahnstrecken die
stromleitungen gekappt worden damit die
leute nicht sehen können wie viel
technik und wie viel soldaten dorthin
verlegt wird jetzt hat unser kollege
julian über ein rap gehört recherchiert
wie aus sibirien wirklich aus dem fernen
osten von schreiber ross und wladiwostok
mit der transsibirischen eisenbahn und
anderen auf und auf anderen zügen massiv
technik und soldaten verlegt wenn also
vom fernen osten ab in den westen ab an
die ukrainische grenze und jetzt auch
nach belarus an vier grenzübergang so
hat die birke dass auch wird auch
recherchiert kommen jetzt russische
truppen darüber nach nach belarus um
auch dort an die ukrainische grenze zu
gehen das sieht also nach deinem
eindruck nicht aus nach einem ganz
normalen manöver sowie putin es ja
darstellt nein das war es wladimir putin
macht ist momentan er fängt an den
kalten krieg nach zu spielen er hat
nicht mehr den warschauer pakt aber hat
so ein so ein rumpf gebilde mit mit
ehemaligen staaten wie tadschikistan
kasachstan anderen staaten unter hosni
bezahlen quasi jetzt dafür mit dass sie
von von putin land geschützt werden und
der spielt wirklich den kalten krieg
nach er geht voll auf eskalation er
verlegt alles was an technik hatten
momentan an die westgrenze hat
angekündigt auf kuba truppen mindestens
und waffen zu stationieren und auch in
venezuela also wirklich ergeht an die
nato grant ganz heran und wirklich bis
nach oben und bis an die zähne bewaffnet
dass es mehr als 30 jahren niemals
gesehen haben warum macht er das weil er
zurück auf die weltbühne will und
wladimir putin kann im land das ist ein
wirtschaftlich heizwerk in seiner
amtszeit hat sich der rubel halbiert er
kann das kann das aufstiegsversprechen
an die eigenen mittelschichten nicht
mehr erfüllen also es ging ganz lange
vielen russen sehr sehr gut die konnten
wunderbar damit leben dass ihr landen
schlechten ruf hatte und dass wladimir
putin nicht sonderlich anerkannt war und
dass russland auch als wirtschaftlicher
und politischer zwerg kalt so lange wie
sie sich die reisen ins ausland leisten
können wie sich ein neues auto kaufen
konnten das funktioniert mit dem
abgewerteten wo wir nicht mehr in im
land eine massive krise und er muss
zurück auf die weltbühne weil er weist
das ja sonst zwischen den usa und
zwischen china einfach bedeutungslos
wird du hast mit den menschen auf der
russischen seite gesprochen was sagen
die imponiert ihnen dieses machtgehabe
also dadurch unterwegs das ist ein
militär gilt gebiet hat da sprichst du
damit ehemaligen offizieren viele von
ihnen waren in der ddr früher mal wie
stationiert oder woanders im
ostblock und die die trauern ihrem
warschauer vertrag nach die trauern auf
den alten zeiten nach man darf wirklich
nicht vergessen die kriegen 24 stunden 7
tage nur staatspropaganda es gibt ja in
russland keine freien medien mehr bis
auf die nowaja gaseta den kommt 3 die
haben doch drei mal einer woche sonst
gibt es wirklich nichts mehr und es gibt
wo die staatspropaganda und dann gibt es
die russen die gar nicht reden machen
den kopf runter und wir sagen das ist
politik ich beschäftige mich nicht mehr
mit politik das ist das was man auch
schon von früher kennt den kopf runter
gesenkt halten und hoffen dass man dem
staat und der politik nicht begegnet
dass man nicht an weckt es gibt angst
aber die meisten leute sagen toll putin
bringt uns wieder wieder zurück wir sind
wichtig wir müssen auf die weltbühne
zurück wirtschaftlich ist russland wie
gesagt aber ein zwerg vielen dank peter
und jetzt wissen wir also worüber wir
reden und zwar mit dem chef der nato
keinen geringeren als jens stoltenberg
chef des größten
militärbündnisses der welt dem teilweise
mein kollege jetzt die richtigen fragen
stellt
[Musik]
und ich begrüße herzlich hierbei bild im
newsroom den nato-generalsekretär jens
stoltenberg herzlich willkommen wir
reden über kriegsangst in dieser so
ernsten situation kriegsangst in
schweden zum beispiel dort habe ich die
bilder irritiert von panzern auf gotland
gegen wegen putin in der ukraine haben
die menschen angst kriegsangst wegen
putin rechnen sie mit einem krieg in
europa
eine echte gefahr für neue militärische
konflikte in europa denn was wir sehen
sind ganz signifikante militärische
bewegungen von russischer seite in der
nähe von der ukraine mit
hunderttausenden von soldaten mit
schwerem gerät und schwerer bewaffnung
das kombiniert mit einer bedrohlichen
rhetorik aus russland und wir kennen
natürlich auch die politische geschichte
usa ist nämlich dass auch in 2014 in
russland schon militärische gewalt gegen
die ukraine angewendet hat und alles
zusammen genommen bedeutet dass es ein
echtes risiko darstellt deswegen ist es
so wichtig einen politischen dialog mit
russland aufrechtzuerhalten wie
deutschland das blut wie die nato das
tot wie wir das tun weil es eben wichtig
ist zu versuchen einen politischen weg
lieber tief in das gleiche ich möchte
einmal bei diesem gefühl der menschen
bleiben von sammer hat das gerade auch
aus der ukraine geschildert diese ganz
reale kriegsangst die hier aus dem
warmen studio in berlin weit weg scheint
aber ja gar nicht weit weg es spüren sie
diese kriegsangst der menschen können
sie die mitfühlen nachfühlen
ich verstehe natürlich dass menschen
bedenken haben besorgt sind und das ist
auch der grund weshalb wird das alles so
ernst nehmen denn letztlich geht es um
die sicherheit von fast einer milliarde
menschen die in den verbündeten ländern
leben und natürlich auch der menschen
die in der ukraine leben aber wenn es
darum geht welche menschen in den
nato-ländern leben dort haben wir die
stärkste militärischen verband oder bzw
allianz der welt mit mehr als 30
verbündeten und wir sehen auch wie
wichtig es ist dass nordamerika und
europa zusammen in der nato wirken und
deswegen ist es so wichtig es nicht
zulassen dass es raum für
missverständnisse oder fehlberechnungen
gibt wenn ein verbündeter der nato
natürlich angegriffen wird dann haben
wir unser kernprinzip einer für alle
alle für einen eine angriff auf eine von
uns ist ein angriff auf alle viertels
und deswegen haben wir immer auf starke
abschreckung und auf prävention gesetzt
damit wir konflikte briten präventiv
abwehren können mit der ukraine gehören
sie unterstützen in ihrem recht auf
selbstverteidigung möglichen reimann an
die truppenbewegungen von russischer
seite aus angesprochen richtung
ukrainische grenze direkt davor stehen
tausende panzer 10 tausende russische
soldaten das sehen wir auf luftaufnahmen
auf
aufnahmen von journalistenkollegen wie
gehen sie persönlich damit um wie gehen
sie in der nato damit um wie bewerten
sie das sind das ganz konkrete
kriegsvorbereitung
nun also das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
dass der russische trocken zum teil auch
an der ukrainischen grenze stehen aber
einige von ihnen auch schon auf
ukrainischem gebiet sie sind auf der
krim das ist
ein englisches gebet das sind
historische grenzen russland mal
anerkannt hätte und auch in madonnas und
dem duo hans stehen sie das ist auch
ukrainisches gebiet wir reden also von
russischen truppen bewegungs in und nahe
der ukraine 2 2 verfolgen wir das
natürlich sehr eng wir haben
entsprechende geheimdienstinformationen
auch für die heimat und wir verfolgen
den russischen bewegungen sehr sehr
engmaschige was wir außerdem tun ist
dass wir ganz klare botschaften an
russland aussenden wir haben gesagt dass
wenn die ukraine angegriffen
wird das ist sehr schwerwiegende
wirtschaftliche finanzielle und
politische sanktionen geben wird und
dass natürlich die nato alliierten auf
unterschiedliche art und weise die
ukraine unterstützen damit sie sich
unter damit sie sich verteidigen können
damit die kosten für russland in einem
solchen manöver so was in mir zweifel
auf der ukrainischen seite unter den
menschen ob das so ist ob die sich
verlassen können auch sie auf uns alle
im westen ob wir wirklich stehen wenn
die in allergrößter not kommen wenn es
eine russische invasion gibt also
menschen wie diese marta die paul
ronzheimer gerade vorgestellt hat die
dort gerade trainieren die zivilisten
sind können die sich auf sie können sie
sich auf die nato verlassen
sie können sich auf unsere unterstützung
verlassen es wird politische
unterstützung für ihre territoriale
integrität und souveränität geben und
als nato geben wir ihnen
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten werden
denn das kapazitäts ausbildung wir
helfen ihnen ihre sicherheits und
verteidigungsindustrie zion zu
modernisieren und die alliierten
verbündeten bieten auch schulung und
training an kanada großbritannien die
vereinigten staaten und andere
verbündete bieten rat ausbildung und
auch einige schlüsselelemente der
militärischen ausrüstung an aber es gibt
einen unterschied zwischen nato partnern
und der ukraine denen wir eben
unterstützungen bieten aber bei
alliierten da haben wir eine
hundertprozentige sicherheitsgarantie
das heißt wenn ein nato verbündete
angegangen würde dann gibt es eine
reaktion der gesamten allianz und die
ukraine ist eben kein nato mitglied das
heißt wir unterstützen die ukraine wir
helfen der ukraine und wir versprechen
dass es ökonomische also wirtschaftliche
sanktionen gegenüber russland geben oder
aber die sicherheitsgarantien erstrecken
sich nicht auf die ukraine alle tarife
um unterstützung durch militärischen sie
equipment angesprochen ja auch hier aus
europa aus großbritannien beispielsweise
richtung ukraine die bundesregierung
sagt aktuell nein kann man sich wenn die
frage danach kommt sie sind jetzt nicht
teil der bundesregierung aber kann man
sich dann dagegen aussprechen kann man
dann einfach in die büsche schlagen und
sagen nein
nun zunächst einmal haben eine nato
verbündeten auf deutschland schon
unterstützung für die ukraine angeboten
haben uns zwar durch die nato
organisationen und institutionen es gibt
dort entsprechende programme der city
building wie schon erwähnt habe und es
gibt verschiedene praktische
unterstützungsmaßnahmen für die ukraine
damit sie ihre sicherheit und
verteidigungs institutionen auch stärken
können zusätzlich dazu bieten wir eben
auch in form von verschiedenen nato
verbündeten die ihre eigenen
entscheidungen getroffen haben hier eben
auch unterstützung in form von
beispielsweise
panzerabwehrwaffen und es entsteht der
nato nicht zu die aktivitäten einzelnen
atomen mitgliedstaaten beurteilen aber
wir begrüßen ist natürlich dass einige
verbündete auch zusätzliche
unterstützung bieten und deutschland hat
gerade erst erklärt dass sie auch dann
unterstützung in form von cyber experten
wissen wollen denn es gibt natürlich auf
der einen seite die gefahr einer
invasion eines ein augen eines
einmarsches aber es gibt natürlich auch
noch andere aggressive aktivitäten wie
hybrid und cyberattacken männer hybride
angriff oder cyber angriffe und da gibt
es verschiedene möglichkeiten
in den versuchen werden konnte die
ukraine zu stabilisieren oder die
regierung zu nehmen die stabilisieren
und das sind diese verschiedenen
adressen der bundesregierung gibt es
unterschiedliche linie lehmann mit
russland umgehen möchte da gibt es
sozusagen die linie der grünen
außenministerin die eine harte linie
gegenüber putin pflegen möchte und dann
gibt es den kurs der annäherung vom
neuen bundeskanzler von olaf scholz
welche dieser beiden linien ist ihnen
persönlich näher
inhaber ist wissen sie wir haben 30
verbündete internat und natürlich gibt
es unterschiede wir sind von beiden
seiten des atlantiks wir haben
verschiedene partner in verschiedenen
regierung und des wegen des nassen und
unterschiede bei den verbündeten in den
einzelnen probleme fragen aber wenn es
zu den wichtigsten kernbotschaften und
kernaufgaben geht da unterstützen wir
die territoriale integrität der ukraine
und werden auch praktische hilfe
leistungen anbieten einschließlich
schwerer sanktionen so dass russland
einen hohen preis zu zahlen hätte wenn
sie sich denn entschließen die ukraine
noch einmal einzumarschieren und da
haben wir absolutes die gleiche meinung
wir haben ganz klare aussagen von allen
nato verbündeten und sie sehen auch was
wir seit 2014 getan haben als muss man
nämlich das letzte mal gebaut ein bandit
hab da haben wir schwerwiegende sagt sie
ausgesprochen und wir haben auch unsere
gemeinschaftlichen verteidigungs
strukturen noch einmal massiv
verstärkt
einschließlich der auswahl bisschen nach
litauen also wie gesagt ist weiter
schlecht stehen auch weil es stimmen in
der kanzlerpartei gibt zu nord schieben
die sagen lasst doch mal ein
schlussstrich ziehen lasst einmal
frieden
darüber erreichen über nord stream nicht
immer wieder diesen alten konflikte
wieder aufmachen das eine ist die
wirtschaft das andere ist ein
potenzieller militärischer konflikt dass
beides hat miteinander nichts zu tun ist
das so stimmt das
da muss man einfach mal ehrlich sein und
sagen dass wir verschiedene ansichten
unter den verschiedenen nato verbündeten
haben einige sind sehr stark dagegen
dass nur schwimmen zwei als pipeline
eröffnet wird andere sagen dass das eine
wirtschaftliche entscheidung ist ich
habe jetzt festgestellt dass die
deutschen regulatorischen behörden die
arbeit zur genehmigung dieser pipeline
erst einmal unterbrochen haben und ich
denke dass trotz der differenzen
innerhalb der nato ist eben bei diesem
spezifischen projekt
ist auch natürlich immer darum trotzdem
geht dass wir unsere energielieferung
diversifizieren müssen einschließlich
der lieferung von gasen das ist ganz
wichtig ist und sich auch die
internationale energie agency anzuhören
und den entsprechenden generaldirektor
sie gesagt haben das was wir dort erlebt
haben eine manipulation des europäischen
gasmarktes durch russland darstellt
nämlich dass durch die zur rückfahrt das
durchfahren von lieferungen auch die
rheingas speichern immer leerer geworden
sind und dass russland da durch die
möglichkeit hat eben auch eigentlich die
möglichkeit hat ihre gaslieferungen
nochmal zu erhöhen das haben sie nicht
getan und das heißt wir brauchen
versteht berichten unsere und vor allen
dingen ihre aufmerksamkeit in der nato
so ganz wesentlich auf russland aber was
ist mit china als langfristige
systemische gefahr
was ist da die größere gefahr für die
nato aktuell russland langfristig oder
china
nun die nato hat nicht die luxus
situation dass wir uns nur auf eine
bergwertung konzentrieren können wir
müssen mit im gleichzeitig umgehend dass
der aufstieg russlands chinas und dann
die aggression rechnen die
cyberbedrohung dann auch nordkorea die
proliferation mögliche nukleare waffen
und all die anderen konstanz mit rohr
gehen und es war mitgliedsländer
deswegen müssen wir auch mit den
nordamerikanern zusammenstehen deswegen
müssen wir auch unsere allianz
modernisieren und das tun wir wir
investieren jetzt beispielsweise mehr in
der cyber verteidigung in neue moderne
technologien und wir stärken auch das
was wir als nordamerika und europa
zusammen leisten wollen und solange wir
zusammenstehen repräsentieren die nato
50 prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts der
welt und fast eine milliarde menschen
und 50 prozent der mittel der macht in
der welt wenn wir also zusammen stehen
dann werden an unsere verbündeten sicher
sein weil wir in der lage sind und zu
schützen auch garantiert auf unsere
verteidigungsausgaben mal wieder dieses
leidige thema aus deutscher sicht aber
so richtig gut kommen wir da weiterhin
nicht in fahrt wir liegen da auf platz
19 von 30 aktuell in der nato würden sie
diesbezüglich sagen deutschland ist er
eigentlich ein last in der nato
germany war da war deutschland ist ein
hoch wertgeschätzt der verbündete und
wir haben auch gesehen dass die
verteidigungsausgaben tatsächlich
langsam gestiegen sind und wir begrüßen
es auch das ist eben hier bei der neuen
koalitionsvereinbarung der neuen
bundesregierung auch die ausnahme gab
dass die verteilungs aussagen
entsprechend erhöht werden sollen und
dass die bundeswehr gut ausgestattet
sein soll und das wird ein paar
signifikanter investitionen erfordern
deswegen freue ich mich auf die klinik
ihr vormaterial generalsekretär an uns
alle hier in deutschland an unsere
bundesregierung natürlich ganz
speziellen herzlichen dank für ihren
besuch hier bei bild im newsroom jens
stoltenberg der nato-generalsekretär
danke zu euch ins studio thomas
vielen vielen dank an ihren stoltenberg
klares wichtiges interview wir ordnen
das noch mal ein meter titel ist nach
wie vor bei mir im studio peter gebe es
noch mal ein bisschen durch als erstes
sagte jens stoltenberg tatsächlich wir
sprechen von einer signifikanten
signifikanten kriegsgefahr ja eine echte
gefahr für eine echte militärische
auseinandersetzung in europa bei wem
jetzt die alarmglocken nicht reden der
hat den schuss wirklich nicht gehört
also der nato generalsekretär spricht
von einer echten kriegsgefahr in europa
zeigt nur sagen deutschland und vor
allem berlin aufgewacht in diesem
zusammenhang ging es auch um die frage
ob deutschland nicht auch
waffenlieferungen dann an die ukraine
liefern sollte so wie es beispielsweise
großbritannien ja jetzt angekündigt
hatte stoltenberg sagte das ist jedem
einzelnen überlassen war da also recht
diplomatisch natürlich und sprach davon
deutschland tut ja was und zwar indem es
cyber experten schickt ja ist es wichtig
oder ist das jetzt gehen wir alle man
den keller und lachende und kommen
wieder raus deutschland schickt es aber
experten in die ukraine die ukraine ist
da relativ gut selbst aufgestellt die
haben selber eine relativ gute cyber
armee und wenn deutschland 1 momentan
nicht hat dann diese funktionieren dass
cyber abwehr wenn wir also jetzt das
schicken dann sind wir auf demselben
niveau wie sonst auch immer wo wir in
alle möglichen krieger in die nato geht
oder kriege gehen wir nicht in die
auseinandersetzung oder in verteidigungs
fälle dann schick mir ein tornado der
ein paar luftbilder macht das ist dann
immer deutschlands beitrag und wir sind
momentan aus meiner sicht dabei das hat
herr stoltenberg der so eine art
geschäftsführer von der nato ist also
der kann da jetzt auch nicht gegen
einzelne staaten reden also erst dann
angestellter quasi nur aber wenn man das
jetzt mal genau auseinander fummeln
würde was er stoltenberg da gesagt hat
dass er froh ist dass einzelne staaten
13 mehr zu leisten als andere staaten
unter den anderen staaten die dann nicht
mehr bereit sind mehr zu leisten ist
halt wieder einmal deutschland und wir
drohen wieder auf das alte spiel moskaus
reinzufallen moskau hat das wissen wir
in internen gesprächen in den
verhandlungen mit berlin zwischen dem
kreml und dem bundeskanzleramt da gibt
es ein heimplatz denn das ist der
außenpolitische berater von
bundeskanzler scholz der war vorhin
woche im kreml und man hat auch vorher
schon ein telefonat mit den anderen
sachen darüber überein über einen
qualität neu anfangen gesprochen dabei
ist zum beispiel auch ausgehandelt
worden dass deutschland eventuell wieder
in eine vermittlerrolle kommen könnte
das ist das alte spiel dass moskau macht
zettel mit europa oder der nato einen
konflikt an oder nimmst du die stärkste
partei die größte wirtschaftsmacht raus
indem sie zum vermittler machst und dann
ist europa genau das was putin immer
will gespalten und handlungsunfähig wenn
man deutschland wieder herausnimmt und
wieder zwischen der ukraine und russland
vermitteln lassen will in einem konflikt
den russland ja ganz offensichtlich
nicht entschärfen will sonst würde man
ihnen ja nicht ständig wieder anfeuern
man steht auf der krim man steht und
dann jetzt mann steht in der hans und
wenn sich olaf scholz da jetzt aus dem
spiel nehmen ist wenn er dieses spiel
mitmacht dann ist deutschland wirklich
wieder einmal voll auf dem holzweg und
dann fallen wir auf leute wie sergei
lavrov der heute mit der heute mit frau
berbalk stand in seinem haus ministerium
interessen genau gesagt hat darum
gebeten hat dass deutschland seine guten
kontakte in der ukraine vermittelnd
einsetzt aber das hat auch hier ins
deutenberg der nato-generalsekretär
gerade gesagt deutschland spiele dabei
eine wichtige rolle um eben im dialog zu
bleiben nun kann es uns natürlich allen
ja lieber sein im dialog bleiben als als
zu schießen warum bist du denn noch so
skeptisch was die deutsche rolle angeht
weil es bisher nichts gebracht hat wir
haben minsk 1 und 2 wir haben zwei mal
ganz groß verhandelt und und vermittelt
hat sich irgendetwas geändert man hat
ganz ganz am anfang dass er sogar ein
krieger 2014 ist frau merkel einmal mit
herrn mag mit dem mit dem französischen
präsidenten damals nach moskau gefahren
hat sie eingepackt und da kommt wir
fahren da hin und jetzt müssen wir
einmal reden dann hatte man den vorstoß
moskaus gestoppt aber erst nachdem auf
dem feld nachdem mario pohl von
ukrainischen truppen freigekämpft wollen
ist ein strategisch wichtiger hafen und
vor allem der landweg von der krim nach
russland das hat ein ukrainisches
truppen und teilweise freiwillige selber
freigekämpft dann hat putin nachgegeben
dann erst danach ist nichts passiert
überhaupt nichts ich war ja gerade in
der regel die leute fahren da noch auf
und abgefahren rein die technik steht
der russische soldaten stehen da und es
bringt nichts und natürlich muss man
reden bevor man sie ist das alte motto
von sergei lavrov der ist glaube ich 71
jahre alt ist seit 18 jahren fast 18
jahren aus mit minister war vorher bei
der un sein altes motto diskus
diskutieren stadt bombardieren
zitiert er leider immer öfter rückwärts
nämlich bombardieren stadt diskutieren
wir haben das in syrien gesehen wir
haben das in der ukraine gibt gesehen
und wenn wir eine lektion zu lernen
haben dann ist moskaus worten nicht
trauen kann das habe bei der krim
gesehen interessant in diesem
zusammenhang jens stoltenberg sagt da
habe es schwere sanktionen gegeben und
russland musste einen hohen preis zahlen
das hätten wir ja damals gesehen aber
das hat leider putin nun nicht wirklich
beeindruckt er ist immer noch dort ja
der ist immer noch dort und so lange wie
er seine erzählung dem russen beibringen
kann wie die alte erziehen und die
russland seit 1917 ging die russen immer
dieselbe erzählung wir sind umstellt von
feinden jeder will uns nur böses wir
können uns nur selber daraus helfen wir
können uns nur auf uns selbst verlassen
und um unsere feinde zu besiegen und um
die abzuwehren müsst ihr leider gottes
ganz viele abstriche in die müssen wir
noch etwas darf das ist die erzählung
die sich durch zieht durch die
sowjetische und jetzt auch durch die
russische geschichte und diese erzählung
wird immer weitergemacht in russland mit
den kaputten autos in denen in den
heruntergekommenen dörfern haben sie
immer diesen slogan drauf nach berlin
nach berlin das ist das alte kriegs
motto auf nach berlin das ist auch dem
verrosteten verrotteten lara drauf und
das ist er ist sehr stolz und davon
zehrt das system wolfgang ischinger der
chef der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
hat gestern hier bei uns beide live
gesagt man müsste den russen klar machen
welchen preis sie bezahlen würden nach
dem interview mit jens stoltenberg ist
putin klar geworden welchen preis er
zahlen muss nein also putin weiß auch
nach dem interview mit jens stoltenberg
dass er sein ziel erreicht hat die
ukraine es nachrichten nicht
nato-mitglied die sind auch nicht reif
arbeiten doch nicht mal in dem in dem
stadium nato-mitglied zum werten und den
stoltenberg hat gesagt was der
unterschied zwischen einem nato
verbündeten also einem mitglied oder
einem partner der partner kriegt eine
ausbildung da wird eine ausbildung
geholfen da werden offiziere ausgebildet
wird da wird eine technik geholfen der
wird politisch unter unterstützt oder
macht man flankierende sanktionen aber
was ihren stoltenberg jetzt auch gesagt
hat ist das stand jetzt die nato als
bündnis da nicht eingreifen würde darf
sie auch nicht sie darf nicht einfach
eingreifen aber ich gehe mit dem an der
wette ein es wird einzelne nato staaten
geben die der ukraine bei stehen nur das
als ganzes bündnis wird es nicht sein
und deutschland wird militärisch stand
jetzt den nicht beistehen das werden
dann großbritannien und frankreich sein
das sind dann die alten alliierten gegen
die man schon mal mit für die uns damals
mal gerettet haben und wir werden
wahrscheinlich seiner chicen selber
agenten und irgendwo in minsk oder
sonstwo
verhandeln also ihren platz geschossen
wird peter thiele ganz herzlichen dank
für die einordnung hier im studio nach
dem großen interview mit nato chef jens
stoltenberg der chef des größten
militärbündnisses der welt der hierbei
bild live gesagt hat es gibt eine reale
kriegsgefahr hoffen wir dass der dialog
am ende gewinnt herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit schönen tag noch